President Trump is making single-life
braid again at least for one Florida
woman who says she's divorcing her
husband in part over his inability to
deal with her love for the
commander-in-chief
according to divorce records Palm Beach
State Attorney Dave Arenberg and his
wife Lynne Arenberg the former Miami
Dolphins cheerleader are parting ways
for a variety of reasons ranging from
Muslim willingness to have children to
her politics quote a staunch Republican
and supporter of President Trump Lynne
also said she felt increasingly isolated
in their marriage their public relations
release stated Ehrenberg is a Democrat
Lynne is a Republican it wasn't an issue
at first but that was before the Hillary
Trump saga I should explain and as that
built the tension in our relationship
built David Ehrenberg was tangentially
involved in the 2016 election when he
dropped assault charges against then
Trump campaign manager Corey Lewandowski
he worked with Trump at Merrill our ago
for years but after Trump's political
rise he tried to distance himself I'm
walking through red carpet Lyndon state
and he's snaking through the bushes he'd
asked me not to take pictures he
wouldn't want me to post them I didn't
listen to him she said she took selfies
with Trump at her husband didn't like it
obviously Lynne is hungry for some
publicity but there are a few lessons
from this tragic tale of marital woe
first to publicity hungry people
probably shouldn't marry each other this
seems like a lesson that the scare
emojis have also learned in the recent
past their agendas obviously weren't
aligned and if mrs. ehrenburg's agenda
deviated from her husband she seemed
happy to ignore his agenda in favor of
her own and vice versa
second people have different political
preferences should think seriously
before tying the knot politics often
reflects deeper values and while we're
fond of papering over those differences
because of her the reality of marriage
requires that two people share a set of
values in order to live a successful
life together
finally the Trump era has polarized
people in a unique way
that's because Trump himself is
polarizing he's loud he's brash with a
thousand character flaws that endear him
to some innately and others people tend
to see feelings about Trump as a
referendum on character and that speaks
to the problem with treating our
politicians and celebrities in general
the point of politics is that we have
certain policies and ideas we would like
to see promulgated and politicians are a
vehicle for those policies and ideas the
character of politicians only matters
insofar as it speaks to the
trustworthiness and capable 'no supper
s'en making promises with regard to
policy but now policy has taken a
backseat to the attitude of politicians
we care a lot more about what
Asians are like and what they say then
what we'd like them to do that means
that if someone likes Trump we tend to
judge them not with regard to the
policies they'd like to promote but with
regard to their apparent approbation of
Trump's shortcomings that's often
inaccurate even nasty attempt to improve
motivation and publicity marriages don't
tend to end quietly outside the glare of
the press I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show oh there's a lot
happening in the news I'm still a little
bit wife dad to be honest with you we
had a debate with Chang lugar Eiger last
night at I'm still bad with his last
name but it was a lot of fun over
political on last night huge crowd like
3,000 people we had to move the
auditorium mostly fans of the show fans
of mine it was great thank you all for
coming out really appreciate it we did a
Q&A as well that was fantastic
800 900 people showed up standing room
only there's a real hunger I think for
politics and for and for truth-telling
and honesty in politics and I really do
appreciate that that's that's the case
it was actually a really good debate it
was a substance of debate I was not
expecting it to be to be honest with you
I thought it was going to devolve into
name-calling and nastiness because I
teach shanks debates with Ann Coulter
and Dinesh D'Souza in the last couple of
years but Chang really did stick to the
topics which is fantastic and I think I
did too and it was a really good
back-and-forth I'll let you be the judge
of who you thought won but it was it was
really great we're going to play some
clips of it tomorrow we're pulling all
the clips of it today so it will have
some material tomorrow it was
fascinating and interesting and I think
really good I think we need more of
those kinds of debates also we're going
to get to everything Trump related the
replacements in the cabinet where he
stands what happens with tax reform
what's going on with Trump here a lot to
go through there but before we get to
any of that first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at Birch gold
so you look at the market right now a
lot of people think the market is in a
bubble The Wall Street has been climbing
and climbing and climbing and climbing
and any uncertainty in the market means
that there might be plunge or collapse
if that happens you're going to be
grateful that you put some of your money
in precious metals this is not to say we
shouldn't invest in stocks or bonds go
for it but you should at least have part
of your portfolio in precious metals
because it is a hedge against inflation
against economic vicissitude against bad
things happening all over the world
which could impact the economy that's
what precious metal ownership is all
about that's why you should go over to
birchgold.com slash band that's
birchgold.com slash pen you get a
comprehensive 16 page kit revealing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA with no tax
consequences so that's pretty awesome go
over to birchgold.com slash been they've
an A+ rating from the Better Business
Bureau five star ratings from countless
clients they're the people that I would
trust to invest in precious metals and
again in any climate you should have
some money invested in precious metals
in a volatile political climate and
world climate like we're seeing right
now you should certainly think about
putting some of your money in precious
metals over at birchgold.com slash then
okay so the big news over the weekend we
discussed it a little bit on Friday is
that Reince Priebus is gone so that
happened shortly after we filmed our
show on Friday I post a little Facebook
note about it but the situation
surrounding Priebus being ousted was
really quite incredible so previous was
fired apparently they took him to that
he was there still debate over whether
he had resigned the previous day so
remember we have to reverse chorus for a
second remember Anthony scaramouche he
was hired as the new White House head of
comms and Skinner Moochie had designed
on being the guy closest to Trump that
meant that he wanted to oust previous so
he did an interview on the record with
the new yorker in which he suggested
that Steve ban in order to perform
anatomically impossible acts upon
himself and suggested that Reince
Priebus was a paranoid schizophrenic who
was always afraid someone was out to get
him it turns out someone was out to get
him
a guy named Anthony scaramouche II as it
turns out and after that interview
happened Trump didn't discipline scare
emoji he didn't say anything about skin
when she's saying anything bad he didn't
say that that was inappropriate none of
that apparently according to the New
York Post
he loved the interview of scaramouche
because this is who Trump is a trump is
a combative guy who has a potty mouth
and really likes when people yell at
each other
he sort of finds it entertaining he
really is in terms of personnel a lot
like the Joker from Dark Knight you know
break this pool cue
there's only one slot available
apparently he was angry at Bryan's
previous according to reports which is
just hilarious who's angry at Rhines
that Ryan's didn't fire back at scare
Moochie so he liked that scaramouche she
was saying that Bryan's was a paranoid
schizophrenic who didn't have trump's
best intentions at heart and he was
angry at Reince that ryan's didn't slap
scare emoji back so he can watch the
slap fight which is
a very Joffrey Baratheon thing to do I
mean it's pretty incredible so chosen
the next day Reince supposed that they
apparently run supposedly resigns except
that he didn't really resign he went on
a plane with Trump to Long Island where
Trump did a speech to some sort of
police event which is controversial in
themself and because Trump said
something about how if you're if you're
a police officer don't be too gentle
with suspects like putting a hand on the
top of their head when they get in the
car so they don't bump their head they
just killed somebody why are you doing
that what not some of that but in any
case you know I think that's a bit of
exaggerated I don't think Trump was
openly calling for police brutality but
in any case what what happened is that
Ryan's gets on the plane he comes back
on the plane well they're on the plane
Trump tweets out that Ryan's has been
fired and he's been replaced by General
John Kelly Kelly is the head of the
Department of Homeland Security so Ryan
says I resigned yesterday but that
doesn't explain why I was on the plane
so they get out of the plane and Ryan's
gets in a car with apparently dance
Covino who's one of the comms directors
over at the White House as well as a
newsman and with the third person and
then scavino and Bannon get out of that
car get in another car and drive in the
opposite direction and Reince Priebus
just drives off into the sunset it
really was very much like the scene from
The Godfather you know leave the gun
take the cannoli and Ryan says Ryan so
sort of left there by himself so Trump
now has to paper this over so on Friday
he says Reince is great I love friends
sure I didn't say anything when people
were saying as a paranoid schizophrenic
sure I've been tripping on paper for
months secretly sure I think he's a
doofus but you just great unbelievable
tremendous go John Kelly will do a
fantastic job general Kelly has been a
star got an incredible job does far
respected by everybody a great great
American
Reince Priebus a good man thank you very
much John Keller is a great American
rice cream is easy dude I knew him for a
little while yeah okay so this so
there's a lot of hope when the Trump
administration from from followers then
now that Kelly who's general is in
charge in terms of the White House chief
of staff there will be a little more
structure to this because so far we have
seen the exit of the National Security
Adviser the firing of the FBI director
Trump attacking his own attorney general
we have seen the ouster of Reince
Priebus and we've seen the ouster of
Sean Spicer it's a lot of turnover in
any organization that's a lot of
turnover like here at the Ben Shapiro
show we've actually had the same staff
since day one because we did a pretty
good job of selecting our staff Trump
said he had selected the best people
yeah hard to argue that when you're
firing somebody every couple of months
there's plenty tweet from somebody on
Friday says is Trump aware that he
doesn't have to fire somebody every
Friday because the Friday before was
Sean Spicer and then last week
was itwas Reince Priebus and this is one
of the reasons why you're seeing his
approval rating plummet among
Republicans there's a feeling that Trump
is in over his head and that he doesn't
actually know it he's doing the
combination of the fact that Trump care
went down in flames last week even
skinnier appeal went down in flames and
Trump came into office pledging this is
going to be easy
i'ma repeal Obamacare and the greatest
deal maker who ever was and then none of
that gets done and he doesn't even
really campaign for very hard a lot of
people were very upset about that and
then you combine that with all of the
turnover and his administration and it
feels like he doesn't really know any
students there's a Rasmussen poll out
today Rasmussen has been the friendliest
poll to Donald Trump he's down to 39% in
the Rasmussen ratings ten days ago he
was it excuse me 44% in the Rasmussen
poll so he's dropped five points 61
percent disapproving John Nolte has been
a staunch support rights for The Daily
wire love John he and I disagree about a
lot of things but he's great guy he
writes a he Key's he writes a piece
today about this Rasmussen poll and it's
appropriately brutal he says the failure
of the Obamacare repeal bill maybe for
forever is inexpressibly demoralizing
and infuriating - Trump supporters
whether or not you blame the president
for the failure of the Republican Party
to keep a seven-year promise I promise
that defined them and justified their
existence as a majority from still
assured and reassured us he would make
this happen
Trump ran on getting things done and on
top of tax reform in a border wall
between the u.s. and Mexico repealing
Obamacare was
his three Biggie's the Obamacare repeal
knocks some of the luster off of Trump
and his biggest selling point his
deal-making skills secondly the chaos in
the Trump administration finally became
real with the resignations and firings
of press secretary Sean Spicer chief of
staff Reince Priebus and the newly
installed communications director
Anthony scaramouche's gobsmacking
unforgivably hypocritical breathtakingly
obscene comments leaks to New York
Magazine scaramouche's the man from
hired to get the White House
communications department in shipshape
and to stop all these leaks to the
corrupt media and what is the first
thing that's idiot is does he runs to
the corrupt media leaks like crazy and
causes a massive distraction just when
the Russia story is beginning to
collapse under the weight of the facts
Trump hired this man Trump did this
debacle is on Trump that's appropriately
brutal language I think from John Nolte
who's been a strong strong supporter of
President Trump throughout the primary
throughout the general and as president
he's getting it from all sides as Trump
and I think deservedly so at this point
he needs to do a better job now one of
the things that is is frustrating about
the way that the previous firing was
done is he was fired in such a brutal
and demeaning manner that when Priebus
then went on national TV and said
everything's okay nobody believed them
so he went on national TV and he talked
about how everything is just spectacular
it's just great didn't interview with
Breitbart and you interview at CNN
here's the one from CNN where he talks
you what Blitzer he says everything has
just it could not be better just
unbelievably great he knows I think
intuitively when things need the change
I've seen it now for a year and a half
on this wild ride with the president
that that I love being a part of but he
intuitively determined that it was time
to do something differently and I think
he's right okay so I think he's right to
fire me and replace me I mean this sort
of kind of kiss he asked to reform
Reince Priebus comes off that way
because everybody knows the kind of cast
that's going on inside again that's
scaramouche's fault okay it's government
you went out and made clear what kind of
cast was happening here and that's the
guy Trump chose that's the guy Trump
chose to put his faith in if you want to
project if you want to project stability
this is what's amazing about this Trump
is good at some things one of the things
he's really terrific at and has been his
entire career has been image right
there's been his entire career Trump
actually isn't that great of real estate
but he is fantastic at image
right scare emoji too scared which in
that grade investing but he's fantastic
an image rights government she's the
kind of guy who spent a hundred thousand
dollars to get a cameo in Wall Street
ooh really drops $100,000 to the Comfort
to the studio so you could get like a
five second cameo in Wall Street to one
of the biggest bombs in recent history
it's all about image creation for Trump
if you want to create the image of a
president who's in charge knows what
he's doing this passive-aggressive
tweeting and then sending out your
director of comms to talk about how
Steve Annan wants to suck his own clock
that does not actually that is not
actually forward the agenda in any real
way I mean on the same day the Priebus
was saying that everything is on board
everybody is great this is all terrific
he's now going on national television
having tonight that he's a leaker are
you the leaker in the White House dick
ulis wolf come on give me a break I'm
not going to get into his well why not
respond to his I'm not going to because
it doesn't honor the president it
doesn't honor the president again all
that makes Brian's previous look like
he's a weakling because if you really
wanted to honor the president the
president's the one who hired scare
emoji so what you have is the look of
people who are trying to be one of the
Trump like previous they look like
suckers and the people who are trying to
be loyal in the way scare Moochie is
attacking all the people they perceive
as Trump enemies they look like
sycophants none of this is good for a
White House that is trying to project
calm into an American political system
that is really riled up at this point
now there is some good news in all the
surgeons the economy continues to grow
2.6 percent growth in the second quarter
which is good strong growth Trump has
been saying he wants four percent growth
not going to happen but if he got us to
2.6 percent growth every quarter that's
that strong growth that'd be fantastic
that is largely because then this is I
think a point that a lot from supporters
make that is correct there is a feeling
that no matter what Trump does at this
point with the Republican Congress and
we say it's not going to make things
economically worse you're not going to
see them passing lots of regulations
you're not going to see him taking a lot
of harsh stances against the business
community at least you're not going to
do that the the success of business
relies on predictability if you're a
business owner what you don't want is
your taxes being jacked up every five
minutes or lowered and then jacked up
and lowered and jacked up you just don't
know how to hire people under those
circumstances Trump even his
incompetence provides a certain level of
stability because you know that nothing
is going to get done so you may as well
assume the system that's in place now is
the system that's going
in place six months from now but in
terms of foreign policy this does have
some real ramifications which I'm going
to talk about in just a second but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Realty shares so if you are
looking into investing and one of the
places you want to invest is in the real
estate market but you don't know that
much about investing in the real estate
market you should take a look at Realty
sure so what Realty shares does is
you're an investor who wants to get into
real estate but you don't really have
tons of Kathleen or like 50 grand lying
around
we have $5,000 lying around and qualify
they give you a list of projects in
which you can invest they look at the
projects they bet the projects and then
they will allow you to invest along with
other people basically you pool your
money and you get involved in these much
bigger real estate projects if you want
to use your money to make more money the
best thing that you can do is invest it
I mean leaving your money sitting in the
bank is a complete waste of time and
money you should be taking it out you
should be using it to build business you
can be using it to build your portfolio
you should be using it to build your
real estate holdings
that's what Realty shares does it's re
alt why shares calm Realty shares calm
they demolish the walls between you and
real estate investing you don't need
billions millions even tens of thousands
of dollars to invest in those vetted
real estate assets hundreds of people
are just fractionally reducing the cost
of an initial investment it is free to
sign up and browse investments and all
it takes is $5,000 to make an investment
no hidden fees if you make 200 grand a
year you may qualify you can find out at
realty shares at com / been that is
Realty shares calm / been right now they
have a special offer just for Shapiro
show listeners and that is if you go
today to realty shares calm / Ben you
had $100 toward your first investment so
instead of being 5 grand it's 49 hundred
bucks which is pretty cool
Realty shares is spelled re alt Y shares
calm Realty shares calm / Ben for $100
toward your first investment again don't
leave your money just sitting around
doing nothing for you make it work for
you this is not an offering of
securities private investments are
highly illiquid and risky are not
suitable for all investors past
performance not indicative of future
results securities offered to accredited
investors through North capital Private
Securities member finra s ipeec okay to
go over and check it out realty shares
calm
/ that ok so as I say the chaos when
when it's being shrugged off but there's
just more evidence of chaos it makes
people feel discomforted we've heard now
for well over a year that there was
gonna be a reset at some
like that was going to make people feel
solid first the reset happened with
Bannon and Bannon did a pretty good job
with the campaign as much as I dislike
him personally you got to give credit
where credit is due you did a good job
with getting Trump under control for a
lot of the campaign and then after the
election after Trump was mouthing off
there's vo Keys assembling this
fantastic cabinet and they will keep him
under control and then he starts firing
people in his cabinet and now again
we're getting the same routine we're
getting the same routine now John Kelly
is coming in and now he's coming in as a
strong replacement finally things will
be under control at the White House
here's Jon Karl from ABC News making
that case he comes in as a much more
powerful chief of staff than right
previous ever was if you remember Martha
when Priebus became chief of staff he
was announced along with Steve Bannon as
the chief strategist with Jared Kushner
as a senior advisor now the power of all
three positions theoretically at least
will reside with general Kelley he will
have authority that Reince Priebus never
had but as you know the issue throughout
these first six months is that the real
chief of staff in that way that White
House has been Donald Trump so the
question is whether or not he will truly
cede that authority to general Kelley
and if you'll listen to him so that is
the question apparently general Kelley
was told by his wife do you not take
this job do not do it and the early
rumors were that everything's going to
run from Kelley now and then immediately
within an hour that was debunked
immediately there were people saying
that scare Moochie would not report to
Kelley he would report directly to Trump
once you have many channels of
communication to the top of the line you
got a problem okay at our company I
wouldn't let Mathis talk to me not
Sondra but but but the fact is that we
do have a line of communication when it
comes to serious personnel issues for
example you go up the chain this is true
at any company okay the idea you can
have everybody going to the boss with
everything leads to chaos inside the
administration this is an administration
that needs solidity right now because
they are not getting a lot of policy
wins and so the feeling of chaos has
ramifications one of those ramifications
that you are seeing America's enemies
feeling emboldened there are a couple of
things that have happened in the last
two weeks that make America's enemies
feel like they might be able to get away
with something the first thing I think
that happened is Trump attacking his own
attorney general but not firing him I
actually think that it's not just the
attacks on sessions that are bad but if
you are going to attack your own AG you
need to fire him okay you need to
demonstrate that you are a strong guy
not a
chling who just whines about the people
he works with I don't go around the
office whining about the people who work
for me if I don't like them I fire them
that's what bosses do okay if Trump is
the biggest boss in the world which he
is then if you are Trump and you don't
like your AG and you keep them around
that makes it look like you do not have
a credible commitment to actually carry
through your commitment that's why GLAAD
Miren putas now starting get aggressive
you expel a ting 755 American diplomats
over the weekend North Korea fires off
another missile they say this is an ICBM
that is capable of hitting large swathes
of the United States we're seeing
America's enemies begin to get more
aggressive and here's the question is
this a White House that is prepared for
disaster is this a White House that is
prepared for bad things to happen
remember with all the chaos with all the
tumult with all of this happening
nothing externally bad has happened to
the Trump administration the economy has
been very solid the economy has been
very strong on the poor and on the
foreign policy sphere no major moves has
actually been made
Landro Putin is not making major moves
yet China is not making major moves yet
everybody was trying to figure out is
Trump bluffing or is Trump really a
crazy guy who might do anything yeah
after Syria after Trump hit Syria with
the missile there was a feeling like we
just can't predict this guy he might go
nuts and he might fire a missile now it
looks more like what Trump is is
actually very predictable he's not
unpredictably unpredictably crazy which
might actually be a good thing this is
one of the cases for Trump on foreign
policy but he might actually be super
predictable that is he has a knee-jerk
response to aggression which is he fires
a missile
but then he chickens out then he decides
you know what I can't do anything here I
don't want to risk my own image and
political capital to do anything and you
could see America's enemy start to take
advantage that's why Mike Pence is
flying over to a lot of the NATO
countries trying to reassure them that
they were protected from Putin if I were
a NATO comment country right now I would
be a little less sanguine about the
prospects that President Trump would
intervene should Russia start to
actually get aggressive in any serious
way Trump is the image of the presidency
matters that's why people elected Trump
they elected Trump to be the image he
was on TV the strong powerful leader
right this is still his image according
to polls the strong powerful leader
who's effective at what he does right
now he has not been effective right now
he does not look strong right now he
looks like he is presiding over a
chaotic household he looks like a
stepfather in a chaotic household where
no one knows where dinner is coming from
the
tonight that is not what you need from
the President of the United States it
has some predictable effects for health
care as well we'll talk about that in
just a second but for that you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you too
can be a subscriber for over the daily
where you get the mailbag you get the
rest of the show live we are not just an
audio show we're a video shows you can
see the show you're going to want to see
the rest of today's show but you're
really gonna want to see tomorrow's
jokes I'm going to show clips of my
debate with tank yesterday which was
just great you're going to go over and
subscribe to get my show you get Andrew
Clavin fantastic show live on video is
to be part of his mailbag you get the
Michael Noel's show which premieres
today god help us and we'll find out how
that goes but you can see the disaster
unfold in real time if you subscribe
right now at $9.99 a month or you get
the annual subscription for $99 a year
for $99 a year it is not just you get
all those other things as well as the
website ad free you also get this
magnificent incomparable unbelievable
spectacular leftist here's tumbler H in
beautiful silver from Daenerys Targaryen
dragons right here on to the tumblr and
says left this year's hot or cold
something that you will treasure forever
it will in fact as I said before if ever
again Indiana Jones has the capacity to
choose a cup from Hmong many to be the
holy grill even though he knows his face
will melt off if he chooses the wrong
one he would be unable to not choose
this particular leftist Cheers tumblr so
you can get that for free when you
subscribe get an annual subscription for
$99 or just listen later in iTunes or
SoundCloud leave us a review and
subscribe we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you
so the impression of chaos inside the
administration has real politic
ramifications one of those ramifications
as we saw last week was the fact that
Trump was not able in any real way to
rally support behind any form of a
healthcare belt and you saw him yes it
like last week he tweeted out
Republicans pass pass health care to
make it better
do it and John had horrors from
commentary magazine he said what exactly
is it and I tweeted back it John it and
that's sort of the problem you don't
know what it is so when Trump supports
something you don't know what it is that
he is supporting and so I think Trump
actually made a bit of a boo-boo so
Trump has been saying openly and
publicly we need to let Obamacare
implode let it collapse let it implode
let it collapse let it go down in flames
he's actually not wrong okay Obamacare
is a crappy scheme Obamacare is a
garbage scheme but the idea that you are
going to let Obamacare implode that's
something you don't say out loud that
something you say in strategy sessions
so to give you a point of a point of
contrast go back to 2013 Ted Cruz says
we're not going to fund Obamacare from
the from the Congress of the
Congressional side and we're not going
to pass a budget that includes funding
for Obamacare and Obama says fine I
won't sign a budget that doesn't include
funding for Obamacare so what does Obama
do right the government shuts down when
it turns out when the government shut
down nothing bad happened everyone was
pretty much okay
the zombies did not wander the streets
there was no foreign invasion members
the military were still getting paid
everything was still basic Social
Security checks were still going out you
know everything was still basically
working because essential services still
run in a government shutdown everything
was basically okay but somehow Obama had
to suggest to Americans that true
disaster was waiting just around the
corner so what did he do he quietly went
out and he closed open air war memorials
he closed the national parks you
remember this is a big scandal at the
time this back in December 2012 I
believe in January 2013 and he was doing
it on purpose right he was clearly
shutting these open air war memorials
where again it's an open-air memorial
it's literally just a statue in a park
and he was closing them down and putting
chains around them and preventing people
from getting it preventing war veterans
from getting in to visit memorials to
their war buddies he was doing all of
that in order to up the pain factor and
we on the right were going nuts I
remember we're saying he's doing this on
purpose because he's trying to make
something that isn't that bad into
something
that is absolutely terrible so that he
can put pressure on the American people
and that's gross he got away with it
because he was smart enough to recognize
that he couldn't openly hit it now
imagine how that would have gone if he
had said that if you'd said listen we're
in the middle of government shutdown you
know and in a government shutdown I
understand things aren't that bad but
I'm gonna make things worse I want you
to feel the pipe and if you feel the
pipe I think that you will be more
likely to support my agenda it would
have undercut his agenda right we
already gone that's kind of a douchey
thing to do really we all would have
said that seems kind of yucky so that's
what has to happen with Obamacare so
what Trump really should be doing right
now he should be saying well the
Obamacare structure is unworkable we're
seeing in many many states Obamacare
exchanges don't have even a single
provider the individual market is being
crushed by the weight of these
regulations and President Obama was
signing over illegal subsidies he was
trying to he was trying to buck up he
was trying to fill in the gaps in his
own crappy plan by doing something
illegal and I don't care what the
Supreme Court has to say about this
there is nothing in Obamacare that
allows me legally to give funding to
these insurance companies and so I'm not
going to give funding to these insurance
companies if States want to fill in the
gaps that's their business but Democrats
need to relieve the regulations if the
prices are going up that's because I am
unwilling to cheat I am unwilling to
spend money that is not allocated by law
in order to prop up a Democrats crappy
system I'm not going to do that because
that crappy system is foreclosing us
from having a better system and if
Democrats want the system to continue
sucking then it's on them it's not on me
I'm just following the law as it's
written and I'm not going to participate
in bailouts just because the insurance
just because the Democrats want me to so
that's what he should say here's what he
actually says which is saying what his
actual strategy is maybe in his own head
now the last part by the way all
everything I just said is true
right I wouldn't even be him lying all
that is true but instead here's what he
says women advice are turning the tide
in the battle against ms-13 but we need
more resources from Congress and we're
getting them Congress is actually
opening up and really doing a job they
should have approved healthcare last
night but you can't have everything boy
oh boy
they've been working on that one for
seven years can you believe that
to swamp but we'll get it done we're
good
you know I said from the beginning let
obamacare implode and then do it I
turned out to be right
let Obamacare implode okay when he says
that it sounds like he is now taking
ownership of Obamacare imploding right
that's like the case where okay there's
a there's a person who's drowning in a
river and you say okay well how can we
save that person there are two ways to
save the person one is there's a person
who's a better swimmer than you and you
need to incentivize that person to go
swim so you say listen I can't do it
right I'm not capable of actually saving
that person I can jump in the river but
I can't save that person there's no way
for me to save that person you should go
do it or we can work together and we can
go out there together and try and save
that person right or what you could do
is you could take let him drown let him
drown the problem with the pr4 let him
drown as it sounds like you're okay with
letting people's around right and this
is what the emma-crats are going to do
this is a campaign ad for Democrats okay
what they're going to do is they're
going to cut let Obamacare implode with
the rising premiums now they're going to
say the rising premiums are Trump's fall
because you could prevent this but he's
not going to prevent this he tweeted out
this morning from between if Obamacare
is hurting people and it is why
shouldn't it hurt the insurance
companies and why should Congress not be
paying with the public pays so I think
so I agree totally what the Congress
should be paying what the public pays
force them into the individual markets
they live with the consequences of the
system they've set up for everyone else
totally fine with that but why shouldn't
it hurt the insurance companies is a
Bernie Sanders argument that is not a
conservative argument the reason
insurance companies right now are
charging higher premiums is because of
the Obamacare regulations when you say
things like why shouldn't it hurt the
insurance companies that's Bernie
Sanders's case Bernie Sanders says what
we should actually do if we want to hurt
the insurance companies is we should
just nationalize the whole thing
Medicare for all medve kapha all right
that's the routine that they are pushing
toward so again how you approach the
issue matters I want to see Obamacare go
probably far more than president Trump
does I've said from the beginning
Obamacare actually corrupts the soul of
the country but you know President Trump
is pursuing the right goal in the wrong
way and every time you pursue the right
goal in the wrong way you end up not
achieving the goal and actually
undercutting the goal you can see how
this is all a democratic ad right Chuck
Schumer yesterday starts to use it as a
democratic add here the Senate Minority
Leader president
Trump did a tweet last night and a tweet
this morning not presidential his tweet
last night said we're going to let the
system collapse we're going to hurt
innocent people because we're angry we
lost politically that is small that is
not what a president does and I hope our
Senate colleagues our house colleagues
on his side of the aisle will turn a
deaf ear on that okay so you at the
Democratic ad you can see it playing out
in real time and they're going to be
Republican to go along with that
Democratic ad like Susan Collins from
Maine who is a quote-unquote moderate
Republican she now is trying to take
ownership of this whole thing she says
health care is in our court right if we
don't fix it it's our fault President
Trump as you know is hoping to revive
the effort to repeal and replace
Obamacare he needs the vote of one more
senator in order to flip someone's vote
whether yours or Murkowski or McCain's
the president appears to be threatening
to cut off funding for the health care
plans that members of Congress receive
would that kind of pressure change your
vote no but you know the ball is really
in our court right now there are serious
problems for the ACA we're seeing
collapsing markets and some areas of the
country where even though people have
subsidies they're not going to be able
to buy an insurance policy so our job is
not done and what we need to do is to
remember my friend Lamar Alexander's
words which is that he says that
Congress doesn't do comprehensive well
we need to go back to committee to the
help committee what he's doing so he's
probably really driving a unified health
plan from the right and the left is she
really doing that or is what he's doing
actually creating opposition to himself
from the quote unquote moderate
Republicans like Suzanne Collins and the
left that's going to blame Trump for
everything now it's not good PR Bernie
Sanders again he actually did this last
night right this is Bernie Sanders
yesterday saying Trump also said they're
trying to dump it on Trump and Trump is
making it easy because he's actually not
doing the one part of his job he's
supposed to be best at the imaging right
that's the party's supposed to be a
master at that's the part where he's
supposed to be dominant that's the party
doing the worst here's Bernie Sanders
looking all weird with the tongue out of
his mouth here
about how great for his room guys
talking about how Trump is going to
threaten all Americans as well as my
pudding cup and perhaps my second
vacation home you know I really think
it's incomprehensible that we have a
President of the United States and
what's the sabotage health care in
America make life more difficult for
millions of people who are struggling
now to get the health insurance they
need and to pay for that health
insurance maybe the president should put
down his stopped his quit twittering
tweeting for a while and understand that
America today is the only country only
major country on earth not to guarantee
health care to all people and the
solution is not to throw tens of
millions of people off of health
insurance that they currently have okay
so this is their whole stick and they're
going to beating those drums Trump needs
to do a better job with this now that
said I think there's a critique that's
growing among some people who were not
Pro Trump during the last election cycle
that I think is wrong and I think it's
actually wrongheaded it's kind of
interesting so John Kasich says that
because of John Kasich god help us that
work John Kasich John Kasich Florida the
occurence Ohio Governor a Raisin in the
Sun John Kasich I'm talking about how
Trump's first six months have him
worried for the country I'm worried
about our country obviously Chris and
here's the thing you know the White
House is Romney winery solution it has
great power but when I think about the
people who have been able to lend voice
to amplify that power what we need and I
think perhaps the president can get
there i sur hope so is sort of the sense
of unity of hopefulness not of division
but of lifting and and I think we're not
seeing enough we're not seeing that
right now okay so he's very critical of
Trump he's always been critical of Trump
he also looks like a wadded piece of
paper the one through your pocket in the
wash
in any case John Kasich doing this
routine you know that he's just
discouraged by the state of the country
Jeff Flake did the same thing in Arizona
he says the GOP has lost its way we may
have we may have lost what we were
supposed to be I think similarly today
the party is lost its way
we've given into
nativism and protectionism and I think
that if we're going to be a governing
party in the future in a majority party
we've got to go back to traditional
conservatism limited government economic
freedom individual responsibility
respect for free trade those are the
principles that made us who we are okay
so I agree with his basic principles but
the idea the party is given in two
nativism or any of this stuff
I think that's an overreach into what
2016 was listen I've worried about this
stuff too I've talked about it
repeatedly I've said that I think that
you know the anti trade tendencies of
the Republican Party they're playing
follow the leader but what I'm actually
seeing I'm actually saying it's
encouraging to me if then seeing that
there are still people people who might
disagree on a lot of this stuff who
still have standards for Trump and that
is a big thing that's a big thing
because the fact is if your standard is
going to be the man or your standard is
going to be the principle now your
principles may differ from mine but at
least if you're say if your principles
are still there then we can argue about
the validity of the principles we're not
just arguing about Trump the man I don't
care about Trump the man Trump the man
doesn't matter to me as I've said before
politics used to exist on the basis of
principles right there's a right-left
spectrum it was the x-axis on politics
and you from right to left you know if I
was all the way out here on the right
now there is a y-axis and that is Trump
and people now judge each other based on
whether they are pro Trump or anti Trump
because I am at a zero on Pro Trump or
anti Trump sometimes he's great
sometimes you sucks I don't care you
know I'm still all the way out to the
right here
but because I'm zero on the Trump scale
there are a lot of people who tend to
think that I'm moderate which is bizarre
because I'm the most right-wing person
that I know the problem is that if
you're on the white spectrum and all you
care about is a wide spectrum then the X
spectrum completely disappeared it
completely disappears that x axis
completely disappears you can't argue
with people on a different axis than you
I can't argue with people or on that Y
axis when I'm not even on the y axis I'm
not on completely different axis and so
what I'm actually seeing and I think is
good is that there are people with whom
I disagree who still are holding Trump
to a standards one of those people is
Laura Ingraham I've been very critical
of Laura I think that she was very sick
of panic toward Trump during the
election cycle I thought that she
glossed over a lot of things about him
they're not conservative I think that
she fibs to her audience sometimes about
about what Trump's actual agenda was but
Laura at least has limits
and you see that right so Laura over the
weekend she came out and she said
scaramouche she's the adult right this
is this guy that Trump hired is an idiot
and he's and he's actually undermining
the Trump administration antenna this is
good this is encouraging Tucker Carlson
Newt Gingrich they're starting to say
the same things that means that there is
some standard again I may not agree with
their standard I may think that they've
waited until too long to get upset about
what Trump is doing but at least it
means that there is still a rational
debate that can be had along that x-axis
because I can I can have a discussion
with people who differ from me where
they are on the x-axis I can't have a
discussion with people who just want to
talk about why Trump is God or why Trump
is is Satan that's not a conversation
that's worthwhile having here is Laura
Ingraham basically for one's being
critical of President Trump I think this
is this I'm sorry I like scare emoji I
think he's really talented but this
episode is humiliating to the president
I think it ultimately humiliates him it
does not serve the communication of this
agenda well I'm probably going to tick
him off by saying it but I say it out of
deep love and affection I'm not helping
his agenda at all so you can see that he
Lord is still trying to cater to people
who are all the way up here on the wide
spectrum but she at least has a breaking
point if you have a breaking point you
can be part of the political
conversation if you don't have a
breaking point if you'll stand for
anything or if you'll stand for nothing
from Trump then you're not part of a
rational political conversation user
part of a pro Trump cult or an
anti-trump cult and I'm not interested
in having a conversation with either of
those things okay before I get the
things I like and things I hate first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Skillshare so you live in a very
fluid world with regard to the job
market it's not like you can be in a job
for 20 years and expect you're never
going to increase your skill set and
that you're never going to get better at
your job and you're just gonna say that
for 20 years you know working the same
rivet that's just not the way the
economy works anymore my mom worked at a
film and TV company for 20 years even
she has moved through a series of jobs
more quickly now because the turnover
and the job market is just that much
faster that's why you need to be
constantly and consistently updating
your skill set you need to be learning
new skills in making your resume longer
and better you need to be getting better
at things that's where Skillshare comes
in so Skillshare comm is a service that
gives you 15,000 classes in design
business and more you can learn
everything from logo design to social
media marketing to street photography
they have entrepreneurship branding web
design public speaking they had
illustration watercolor and hand
lettering and calligraphy I've watched
some of their I've watched some of their
tutorials on things like Adobe
Illustrator and it's really edifying
it's great I mean it means that I now
know how to do something I didn't know
how to do they're all 15 minute courses
that allow you to learn about I think
them actually rather 45 minute courses
that allow you to learn about all of
these various topics and you can
increase your skill set on a routine
basis making you more attractive to
employers and making your capacity to do
things much much richer Skillshare calm
right now is giving my listeners a month
of unlimited access absolutely free go
to Skillshare comm slash Shapiro to
redeem that free month again that skill
shared comm Shapiro to redeem that free
month go over and check it out
Skillshare have taken several of their
classes actually and they're all
terrific Skillshare comm slash Imperial
regime that free month increase your
skill set make yourself a better
employee and a better hire or learn the
skills that you need to launch our
business I mean you know Skillshare calm
slash your fear okay time for things I
like and things I hate so things I like
I'm obsessed with the mood I will be
honest with you I think the mooch is the
greatest thing that I have ever seen in
politics because what the hell I mean
just like what in the world and as I
said on Friday one of the problems with
the Trump administration and one of the
glories of the Trump administration is
that if you duck out of the room for
five minutes to take a dump you miss
Laurey news cycles scarer Moochie has
contributed to this in magical ways I do
love a man who who called his book
something like jumping over the rabbit
hole and then said that he did that as a
reference to Lewis and Carroll now Lewis
Carroll Lewis and Carroll you know like
the explorers of the Northwest Lewis and
Clark but in any case it pretty amazing
scaramouche is just the joy and since I
now root for entertainment not just
policy victory I'm starting to give up
on policy decree unfortunately because I
don't see this Congress being effective
and I think this president needs to get
his act together
now that would only for entertainment
scaramouche you must stay it is
imperative that scaramouche you remain
as part of this administration no matter
how many times he says that other
administration other administration
officials are attempting to perform
bizarre sex acts on themselves from SNL
skits with Will Ferrell performing yoga
in any case I've decided to do a whole
series of references to Skinner Moochie
this week in honor
the new White House communications
director that this one is basically
eight versions of scaramouche II in a
suit it is Wall Street the starting
charleshayne in the 1980s Oliver Stone
had a series of films that really quite
good like back to back in the 1980s this
is a film that he made directly after
platoon and of course it's become famous
for Michael Douglas's terrific
performances Gordon Gekko I here's some
of the trailer from a director of
platoon the next battle is in the
creative jungle of them all Wall Street
it all down as I know time the stock is
plummeting when it hits a teen idol
something big is going down I want you
to fill out the missing picture mr.
Gekko that's not exactly what I do or
you can create your honor it is no
license that's inside information for
power you're not inside you are outside
I want you with advice with your trade
your peace of mind just the beginning
pound if any trouble does arise you are
on your own the trail does stop with you
pearl piece of the action and remain
that money all it takes is a little
inside information
I don't care where
hiya static and thank you for my head
you can trade everything you believe in
is yours you can't you can blind assist
or everything you ever wanted I got a
strange call from the FCC a very very
enlightening to us obviously the take on
Wall Street is the wall stories all
based on insider information which is
not your personal there's a good
libertarian argument that insider
information should actually be legal the
reason that they say this is because
they say that otherwise what you end up
with is that the public actually has
less information generally you can
follow a few key players and if you just
followed what the investors were doing
who actually are at the company you'd
immediately know something was going
wrong with the company and sell your
stock so it actually be more transparent
this is the case made by libertarians
thanks actually a pretty strong case
economically speaking that insider
information shouldn't be barred because
people are going to do it anyway and in
fact the people with the ultimate
insider information are people in
Congress who know which legislation is
going to be passed impacting the economy
in any case it's a really cynical take
on Wall Street that is far too broad the
truth is that the vast majority of stock
pickers do not actually outperform the
market one of the great myths of stock
picking is that if you invest your money
at goldman sachs the particular trader
the bad guy is going to be just a wild
success for the next ten years the
number of people who have been wild
successes who outperform the market you
know who picked stocks just they're
great at picking stocks really really
low the market is a highly transparent
and it is very difficult to beat the
market the idea that you can you speak
the market is is you may be may do it on
one-off basis but doing it repeatedly is
nearly impossible but the film itself is
really good and it's funny because
Gordon Gekko is supposed to be the
villain but his greed is good speech
which is basically sort of a 9r and take
on economics not a bad summary of ein
Ron's objectivism and actually true one
of the things that's really funny about
this is that they make out this movie I
can do a whole shtick about the
economics with its moving but they make
out the unions as the great winners in
all of us okay the unions in this case
one of the things that happens in this
movie is that the Union which is run by
Charlie Sheen's dad Martin Sheen in the
film is trying to bargain with an
airline the airline is losing money and
the unions are still trying to claw for
their piece now he makes the union's a
lot more conciliatory then they actually
are in real life but Gordon Gekko looks
at this and he says okay well I'll buy
the airline I'll gut the airline I can
sell it off for pieces it's cheaper to
do that and I'll make more money that
way
bargaining with these unions and instead
of you saying well maybe the Union
should cut a better deal with management
in order for them to operate an airline
in a competitive price right and stop
losing money they makes you feel like
he's the bad guy for coming in and
buying a company and then and then
redistributing the airplane basically
selling the airplanes to more efficient
companies but from the prop from
perspective of the consumer what Gordon
Gekko does is better from the
perspective of the consumer than what
the union is attempting to do in wall
street it's really it's an interesting
counter like if you watch and then dude
the economic counter to it it's actually
a really interesting analysis but it's
kind of cool Oliver Stone who is a
complete nutjob is he's super talented
director he made in this period he made
Salvador with James was which is a very
good movie the next movie made was
platoon which is a very good movie the
next movie he made was Wall Street which
is a very good movie movie made after
that is talk radio which is a very good
movie
and they made born on the 4th of July
which not a big fan of and the doors
which I'm not having tonight in the mid
JFK which again is propaganda but it's a
very good movie talent is Andrew Clavin
like to say talent Falls equally on the
on the good and the evil Oliver Stone is
not a good man who used back for years
the who go Chavez regime in Venezuela
which is now garbage but it's but it's
pretty he is a talented filmmaker for
sure okay time for some things that I
hate
okay so first thing that I hate there's
this run in between chris Christie the
Governor of New Jersey and a Cubs fan is
in a Brewers Cubs game and Chris
Christie is getting a lot of crap for
this but that does not seem appropriate
to me here's what happened
that can bake with that own breakfast if
I had sister she was walking through the
Cubs fan started heckling him and he he
yelled his name apparently the guy said
I yelled his name and told him that he
sucked I called him a hypocrite because
I thought that it needed to be said and
I think it's one thing for Chris
Christie to catch a ball at a Mets game
which I like the last weekend then he
got booted which I was just generally
hilarious but don't like harass the guy
on a personal level okay like as
somebody who is in public a lot it would
be very irritating to me if you just
heckled me on a personal level I I'm
like I'll live with it it's fine it
comes along with the territory but for
people to be getting all over Christie
because Christie went him and said you
know you're you're a big shot before
walking away from the fan I can't get on
Chris Christie's case for that I really
can't and people are all over him for it
not so much okay the other thing that I
hate today is JK Rowling people are so
eager to nail Trump that they are just
saying things about him that are plainly
untrue so there was a video of it looked
like a kid in a wheelchair trying to
shake Trump 10 and then Trump not
shaking his hand but the problem is that
that's not true Trump spent more time
with the kid in the wheelchair than
anyone else is actual video of Trump
with the kid in the wheelchair and it is
not it's obvious that he's not ignoring
the kid in the wheelchair but that
didn't stop JK Rowling we actually we
have the video so this is the actual
video of Trump with the kid in the
wheelchair
[Applause]
so there's a cute local kid in the
wheelchair and people are trying to
suggest that Trump was ignoring the kid
the kid want to handshake first of all
kids like three kids were three don't
handshake really but he was really nice
to the kid JK rowling didn't stop her
again when you are a big name author in
a different field you feel the need to
be a jerk I guess like Stephen King or
JK Rowling she tweeted when someone
shows you who they are believe them Maya
Andrew first of all anyone who quotes
Maya Angelou is just a complete bag of
annoyance when someone come on and she
says Trump imitated a disabled reporter
now he pretends not to see a child in a
wheelchair as though frightened he might
catch his condition hey number one never
happened number two on the invitation of
disabled reporter this is one of those
things where the more I watch and watch
it now probably ten times so I think
it's good know so I think that he was
obviously imitating the reporter I don't
think it's perfectly obvious at all
because Trump does his imitation of like
thing people he doesn't like the same
way every time with this and the weird
voice but in any case she says this
monster of narcissism values only
himself in his pale reflections the
disabled minorities transgender people
the poor women almost related to him by
ties of blood and therefore his
creations are treated with contempt
because they do not resemble Trump my
mother used a wheelchair
I witnessed people uncomfortable around
her disability but if they had a shred
of decency they got over it so yes a
clip of Trump looking deliberately over
a disabled child's head ignoring his
outstretched hand was touched me on the
raw that man occupies the most powerful
office in the free world and his daily
outrages against civilized norms are
having a corrosive effect how stunning
and how horrible that Trump cannot bring
himself to shake the hand of a small boy
who only wanted to touch the president
um
yeah except that that's a bunch of
absolute garbage that thing has 58
thousand retweets and Counting actually
I'm sorry the first one with Maya
Angelou is 160 mm likes so it just shows
you how eager people are to confirm
their biases about particular people
including Trump listen you can be
critical of Trump I'm highly critical of
Trump but that does not mean you get to
make crap up about him that makes you a
bad person
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow I'll
use the full recap of the debate with
Schenk we will have a bunch of clips at
that point and I look forward to seeing
you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
venture Pierrot show
[Music]